[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's adam schefter the adam schefter
podcast debuts
each week adam gives his perspective on
the happenings around the nfl joined by
great guest urban meyer
also uh former wide receiver josh gordon
the eagles quarterback jalen hurts the
adam schefter podcast
subscribe and listen well it was
just about a week ago a couple hours
from now where adam schefter
came on sportscenter and said basically
that aaron rodgers
wanted out of green bay uh walk me
through that
did you get a phone call or text
you know dan the funny part about it is
that i've heard people say oh aaron
rodgers wanted that
out before the draft i can assure you
aaron rodgers did not want that out
before the draft i've had people say
the green bay packers planted that it
was a very pro packer story
yeah i could assure you the groovy
packers didn't plant that
when people guess at where stories come
from
more often than not they're usually
wrong and in this case
they're wrong this was an accumulation
all during the offseason of just
listening to people talk
and observing and if we go back to the
nfc championship game
that the agreement packers lost at home
did we not hear
aaron rodgers after that game talk about
his level of unhappiness if you will
uncertainty for the future just go back
and listen to that press conference and
it sounds
almost like he's saying goodbye to green
bay and so your
antenna is up and i'm just telling you
throughout the course of the all season
there was rarely a week that went by
where i didn't hear something about
aaron rodgers
and on draft day there's a report that
morning from paul allen out in
minneapolis that the
49ers made a draft offer which didn't
make an offer they never made an offer
and other people are saying that the
49ers called and i said
how long till it gets out that aaron
rodgers wants
that agreement is it next week is it
next when he doesn't show the otas
is it next month when is it it's going
to come out what does it matter
if it comes out now or next week or next
month
and so so you chose to break the news on
draft day
that is actually that is absolutely
accurate correct
but it wasn't something that you got
information about
no oh okay okay no there was nothing
that morning that came in
all of a sudden said to me yeah he wants
out you should report this like
you know it was going on all off season
you just keep hearing and there there
was more and more talk and now they're
starting to be on rogers talking i said
you know what
this isn't going to wait much longer
let's just go and it just happened to be
drafted
because i wondered when you said it
didn't come from rogers didn't come for
the packers
and it's being characterized differently
i was wondering okay you're not going to
tell me your source
you know what was the motive behind that
yeah yeah
there's not a source no no i know but i
know that now but
we're just finding this out right now
this is why i said this i said around
the nfl live i said i
said it you know i mean i don't know
people want to believe whatever they
want to believe
it was just an accumulation of
information
throughout the course of the entire
season
did the rams make an offer the rams
inquired in january and again that's an
example i knew when they were calling
and they were quickly rebuffed like the
conversation went nowhere
but they checked in early in january
and they were not the only team that
checked in so by the way
dan why are these teams checking in
because it's
available or their hearing is available
oh where are they hearing that
um are they hearing it from the packers
are they hearing it from aaron rodgers
because it has to come from one of those
two right
well i'm just saying there was a lot of
speculation
in league circles however you want to
characterize that
that he was unhappy and wanted out
and then if you just again go back to
the press conference go back to jeopardy
now he could play jeopardy
he could do jeopardy host jeopardy and
play football he could do that
yeah but he's doing that uh
he's making the comments he's making i
mean
you know it's funny there were so many
people that knew this
of his unhappiness that
i think all i really did was shine a
light on some of
what had gone on the fact that you know
mark murphy the packers
president had flown out to meet with him
the packers gm
brian goudicus had flown out to meet
with him packers head coach matt lafleur
had flown out to meet with him
they're all trying to state their case
plead with him to come back explain to
him why he should be in green bay
and by the way it doesn't appear that
any of them made any progress with him
so this was all going on but what can we
confirm though adam
does he want bryden gouda kunst fired
the gm can we confirm that
i've never said that no no i'm just
saying there's so much
information out that other people have
put out there i
that i don't know what has been
confirmed i mean rogers hasn't said
anything
i mean even you know did he refer to
gouda kunst as
jerry krause i don't know that
but let me say this there's so much
stuff that's floating around
out there some of which is probably true
some of which probably isn't
and i would say this also whatever's
floating around out there whatever is
being said
we probably don't know the majority of
the story
and i'll say this like when tom brady
left new england we think we might have
an idea
but i guarantee you one day we'll hear
more
to that than what was just out there
being discussed on your show or espn or
whatever it may be
and i believe that that's the case ben
rogers we know
he was unhappy with some of the moves
the pack was made we know
that he didn't like that they not only
drafted jordan love but didn't even tell
him
they were drafting jordan love we know
that he has
issues with certain people but we
probably don't know
a lot of the things that really pissed
him off
through the years in green bay that have
been building and plus dan
everybody gets like this i think at some
point in your life you were probably
like this
you get to a certain point he's he got
engaged over the new year
different life he's been there 17 years
right
at some point everybody wants to try
something different you wanted to try
something different at one point in time
did you not how old were you when that
happened dan
uh 50. okay well aaron rodgers is 15
quarterback use
right yeah so but do you know that he
wants
out he still wants out
well i know i believe i do i know
yeah i i i know he wants yeah he i
believe i believe
do i know he wants out what do we know
fully know i
i have been told that he does not want
to be there
by many people okay yeah so you you
whatever that means he doesn't want to
be there well i'm just trying to
separate fact from fiction
rumor from innuendo and and and that's
why
i go to the source that's why i wanted
to have you on because it started
with you now did i hear about the rams
thing
later yes i did um i wondered about the
niners if you gave them a do-over
don't trade those draft picks to the
dolphins and you can have those draft
picks
would the packers have entertained a you
know a trade like that
no i don't i don't believe i don't
believe they would have okay um
you know kyle shanahan called matt
lafleur that night
uh to feel it out to see whether the
niners should make a run
as these men have documented and
quickly was able to ascertain that the
packers had
at that time no interest in dealing
aaron rodgers
and so the talks never went anywhere
just as they never went anywhere
with the los angeles rams but then we
are now in early may
and the packers have held firm to their
stance and the interesting part becomes
now over time
what happens to change this particular
dynamic
does aaron rodgers soften his stance i
don't believe he will
but we'll see do the grievous packers
come off their stance so saying we won't
trade him
i don't know right now they don't make a
decision right the fact of the matter is
they couldn't trade him until after june
1 anyway
due to the salary cap numbers if they
trade them today it would be a 38
million dollar charge
if they traded them post june 1 it would
be split up to 16 and 22 between the two
years
so they can't even do anything for the
next
26 27 days whatever that may be so
there's no reason for them to budge up
that stance they want aaron rodgers to
change his mind
they're going to continue to hold out
hope that he changes his mind do what
they can to change his mind i don't
think he will
but there's no rush right now
so potential suitors here because if you
think there's this stalemate continues
and rogers doesn't want to play at some
point the packers have to cut their
losses and just say okay
hold on but do they dan because they
could just say you know what aaron you
don't want to play anymore
um you're not going to play here we're
not going to trade you and then it's
just a standoff now
i don't think that serves anybody but
nobody yeah nobody wins
but okay do you want to be the guy in
green bay do you want to be the mark
murphy the president the gm
who trades aaron rodgers do you want to
do you want that on your resume then
i think they already chose that
direction by drafting jordan love adam
well i i agree i mean that that that's
where a lot of this
starts a lot of this again how much i
don't know but
certainly a healthy portion of it and
that was their decision
and so again they could say you know as
somebody said to me yesterday each side
has leveraged the packers could say
we're not trading you and if you don't
want to play
you're never playing again and oh by the
way and this would be really petty
and really small and really hard to
imagine but they could say you also lost
30 million dollars
in signing bonus money yeah now i i
can't believe that somebody who's done
so much for one franchise
uh would be subject to that where the
team will come after him for the money
but the packers could do that it's a
business i mean that's
that would be their decision aaron
rodgers
if he says i'm not showing up um they're
in trouble
and so to me i've always felt like aaron
rodgers
wants the green bay packers to do
everything here
he wants them to draft jordan well he
wants them to trade him he doesn't want
any of the mud on his hands
and i've always felt like aaron rodgers
has got to get a little mud in his hands
and not worry about not care
because the mud's going to wash off all
you have to do is say i love green bay
love my 17 years there love the coaches
and i love the players my teammates
but they made their decision last year
and now with everything going on in my
life i'm making mine
it's not that hard right sorry i'm i
know that'll disappoint some people but
that's
that's where he's at why hasn't rogers
spoken adam i
i i don't know that i that's a great
question because he can clear up a lot
of this
rumor innuendo what's fact no no dad
it's not rumored
on it he wants out he wants out he does
not want to be there that's not a rumor
that's not innuendo
he doesn't want to be there well no the
other stuff about you know how he views
gouda kuns you know that like there's
there's other things there you know i
trust what you say that he wants out but
if he does say
hey you know they they they cut my
friend
jake kumaro okay how important was that
to this
you drafted jordan love you didn't give
me a heads up uh do i have my issues
with brian
gudykunst yeah i mean i mean i don't
know
but at some point i think he owes it to
him himself and the situation to just
tell us what you feel what you think
instead of
trying to read into it okay let me ask
you a question i don't think he was at
us
do you ever do do you why did carson
palmer did he restate why
he held out of cincinnati and and wanted
to move do we know the reasons that he
wanted to move on in full well
okay you don't owe it to us but the
packers fans yeah
carson eventually talked about it yes he
talked about he didn't want to play for
a losing organization anymore he didn't
like
he didn't think that the the bengals
were a nfl franchise
you know their practice facility was
horror i mean there's a long thing
list of things that carson talked about
there we ever get a full
full honest explanation from tom brady
about why he left new england
that's fair but but he was free to go
like tom tom could just yeah tom could
just walk away he didn't have to say
anything
he was like correct here's here is my
response to all of this
i'm leaving i'm gonna go play for the
buccaneers
this is different because you got money
that's tied up with aaron
uh and granted you did draft his
replacement in new england jimmy g
but we saw what happened with tom brady
tom went above belichick to make sure
jimmy g got escorted out of the building
he had a power move here's something
interesting dan
this already unfolded this very scenario
unfolded
in the nfc north already this offseason
and no it was not with a super bowl
winning mvp
legendary quarterback but it was with
the former number one overall pick
the lions in matthew stafford went
through this dance already
okay and maybe the green bay packers
and i don't know when we've ever said
this before should take a page from the
detroit lions playbook
and these two sides sat down agreed
that they would be better apart and used
it to their advantage matthew stafford
you know what he wanted
he wounded up in l.a the lions traded
him got
three ones back for that guy so
everybody won
it was not messy it was a clean divorce
but this this is a this is like somebody
said this to me
uh this morning dan they said it's like
the uh couple
that disagrees the married couple where
they one couple wants to go
into therapy uh the other couple wants
to get the other person wants to get a
divorce but they want the person who
who wants to be say we want the divorce
adam rogers doesn't want it
he wants them to do everything he wants
them to draft jordan loves
he wants them to be and then he wants
them to trade him when to me he's just
got to come out
and literally cut the cord for everybody
and say i'm not coming back
but that's why i said he's got to say
something adam you're saying he doesn't
oh
okay but you said he didn't always no no
no
he doesn't he owes the situation so he
can't you want
clarity finality then you can he can he
can
he can create that finality yes clarity
no i don't think he's got to specify
about brian guticunch or jake kumar no
but he will give us clarity that he
truly wants out by saying
i truly want out there now we know
i i want i'm not coming back trade me
how does this all
how does this all play out you're
betting it well
it's it's the biggest question of the
offseason
and it's the biggest question since tom
brady became
a free agent last off season in the nfl
and
again nobody the packers don't have to
do anything
um my guess is nobody will do anything
until they have to
so my guess is they'll be otas later
this month he won't be there
there'll be training camp and does he
show does he
say i owe it to the coaches who i really
like
and the players who i really like to be
there
or does his feeling override all that
and has he made the ultimate decision
his mind it's done and over
and i don't know whether his stance
softens
right like again people change their
minds
that happens in life in football in
business
i couldn't tell you how it's going to
work out all i can tell you is
it is an issue it's a big issue and it's
not going away dan
who's the starting quarterback for the
packers week one
that's a great question right you know i
don't know that jordan love is ready for
that
as much as the franchise invested in him
when you when you talk to people that's
that's the great part so if they if they
move on
if somehow they move on from aaron
rodgers they got to bring in another
quarterback adam
i think so dan i think so dan the way it
was described to me
this all season was i was talking to
people about jordan love
people that have watched in practice and
i said how is he and they
the exact phrase was he's got a long way
to go yeah
i figured hey you're a great sport
coming on and clarifying it i
i appreciate that well i don't know if i
offer you much clarity dan but i tried
to do the best i could
yeah i know well you did better than
rogers is doing right now
thank you buddy adam schefter the adam
schefter podcast
debuts each week and uh the adam
schefter podcast subscribe and list
we'll take a break we'll recap that
right after this
you